la crispation
c'est pas marrant heureusement pour la
première fois en france à remède
efficace contre la crispation maladie
qui fait des ravages dans quelques temps
dans le monde entier vient d'être
apporté des us
c'est un petit sifflet magique véritable
remède miracle pour vous en prouver
l'efficacité nous l'avons essayée sur
plusieurs personnes particulièrement
crispé d'ailleurs regardez vous même
bonsoir madame bonjour mademoiselle est
beau challenge bien ce soir beta partie
la délicate mission de vous éclairer sur
les motivations au néo cartésienne de la
dialectique démocratique alors dans un
premier temps et bien ou très trop de
l'affluence jeu physique du climat sur
l'idiosyncrasie du chef d'état
ce qui nous amènera à formuler une
analyse complète du pouvoir politique
est bien le le pouvoir politique le
chassant vachard via ces faits de tout
petit ria ça se passait sa touchante et
ça revient ça turkia comme une chanson
pop publie alors l'eau à l'épaule a
levels assad veut les faire les
clodettes en fable c'est pas tout ça
j'ai du retard
je veux pas me tenir ici de l'apa
patapédia alors jughurta furtado n'a pas
pâti
vous allez faites vous allez peut-être
me dire que c'est pas le siffler qu'il a
décoincé qu'il était déjà vachement
libéré bon alors c'est pour cette raison
que nous sommes allés renouveler
l'expérience chez un autre personnage à
ces sujets à la crispation
il est inadmissible que de rappeler
comme la france qui se réclament depuis
la nuit des temps
la liberté d'expression ne soyons j'ai
fait aux dénoue les socialistes un
système totalitaire tel d'infortuné
clients d'un supermarché tentaculaire à
la consommation forcée d'une politique
qui nous révulse
il est temps de cesser ce grand commerce
gouvernementale pour vivre un autre
idéal libres de toute pression
eh bien monsieur madame approchez
approchez les belles marotel fraysse
mérogis à épines
approchez mesdames du pétale pour
marcher une pétale bon massa est totale
pour a qu'a appris la presse
vous allez peut-être me dire maintenant
que l'essai n'est pas concluant que ses
volte face n'ont rien d'étonnant de la
part d'hommes politiques qui sont avant
tout de grands comédiens pour vous
convaincre voici un dernier essai tenté
sur une personnalité internationale
vachement stable sa sainteté paul 6 nuls
et du rhum il travaille chez total
praise un sculpteur de la bonne parole
kanda décor tout court et testera
litanie nouveau roman d'amour genou au
musée de l'abeille
nous appelons ce petit sifflet magique
descoings est en vente exclusivement à
la ssp où on rend compte maintenant des
gens absolument adorable où règne une
ambiance super décontracté alors voilà
quatre bon sens ça fait une heure que je
te le dis